we all think from time to time about
uh life in general but
as we're talking about aikido and
arts i was thinking about um
the technical side of aikido
and my my life has been aikido
tai chi yoga meditation
they are the most prominent things that
i've studied
i also do my own healing system
that's led me into deeper deeper
understanding of the mind
and how much more we can
sense with our natural
senses that not so many people use
but we all have the ability to use them
we perhaps
are not interested in tapping them more
that just hasn't come up yet
but why do we start aikido
is uh
it would take a lot of writing if we all
put down
our thoughts while we done it it doesn't
matter what
you went to aikido for originally
you had to go through the blood sweat
and tears of training on the mat
the technical side
it you you step onto the mat and for
that
one hour two hours however long it is
nothing else exists really the outside
world's not there
you're just immersed in enjoyment
suffering trying to
do the techniques better trying to watch
the
teacher what they've just performed
scrambling in your head next time i'll
watch their feet because i didn't know
what their feet were doing or
oh dear what did he do once he'd done
that with his hands well what was the
next part
so our mind's completely consumed
and this for me
was pretty much day after day month
after month year after year
is how my mind went
never really getting the chance to study
who am i and
it's almost like i wanted to run away
from that
looking at myself i might not perhaps
like the person i see
i don't know what it is but you know
it's much easier to
criticize my bad techniques
and hope that tomorrow my techniques
will become
better we then start to
formulate some techniques that we
we do understand and we get better we we
start
performing them better we become
we get favorites
i know a lot of the students that i've
taught over the years
it's a little bit like going to a
restaurant with a set menu
you can have the vegan set menu
or the the meat plate
the chef would have decided what they
wanted to put on
each plate what vegetables
they would cover what sources
and this reminds me of
places that do standard sunday roasts
you sell your table you don't go to
a calvary
i'm talking about the place you just sit
at your table
you've ordered the chicken
or the beef or just the vegetarian
dish it comes with all its trimmings
there might be something on there that
you're not keen on
how will i avoid this i don't want it
tainting or mixing with the things i do
like do you start separating it
on the plate are you becoming a finicky
was it worth going there in the first
place
yes it was because the food's excellent
but it's just something you didn't quite
like
and over the years teaching students
they may
not like the weapons and then in while
my aikido
the training was 50 weapons and 50
taijitsu
but if you were fascinated in the
technical side
of the taijitsu the body arts
the weapons is being forced on you so
you do them
it's a bit like the vegetables
well perhaps this time i'll light them
so you perhaps eat the vegetables this
time i'll perhaps like the ken
or the joe then you may get to a stage
where you prefer the ken
or you prefer the joe from one to the
other
it's really like um
we're never finding out who we are
because we're busy chasing the things we
like the thing
criticizing the things we don't like
really what we're doing is we're
observing
we're observing what we like and what we
don't like as well as knowing what we
look like and don't like
are we being stubborn possibly i've
never met a person yet who's
not a stubborn person
i like to observe people not for the
listening to the gossip on what sort of
person they are i'm not
sadly interested in knowing someone
else's business
i observe how they move how they act
how they use their body
their tones of their voice does it sound
aggressive
their facial expressions before they
talk
is this person somebody who
has a grudge against life
i hope you know what i'm talking about
why is this person smiling they radiate
a smile
i wonder if they're sad within
or whether the smile goes all the way
through
what must it feel like for a smile to go
all the way through to the depths of
your soul
the depth of your being from head to toe
i wonder if oh sensei actually felt that
depth all the way through
eventually or was he as human as me
and until the day
we any of us die will we all be
searching to become better
or shall we deny looking at ourselves
don't be frightened of yourself you're
more than likely
quite a nice person however good or bad
you are
you are you accept the person you are
so i've observed many masters over the
years
even the ones i didn't follow i've
observed them
through the wonderful power of video
form
i've observed them on their seminars
when they've been teaching and i've been
observing how the
students reacted to their teaching
and many of you have been doing this a
long time will know
that you might be sitting on the side
for some reason
you may have an injury or you just
couldn't
go to that seminar to train because of
some reason but you did
go to watch and you ask the question
why are the students not doing what the
sense they just showed
how strange how can i sit sitting on the
bench and yet they can't see it and
they're on the mat
training with him for her
i remember watching scentsy pat hendrix
now said her she's always helped the
students
on every seminar she'll go around
correcting them
giving them pointers helping them
but it's like walking with a bucket full
of holes
as soon as she leaves them they seem to
be lost it's like a puppet without any
strings
it collapses their knowledge
and they appear to be lost it's as if
her energy and her instruction
was allowing them to be the puppet to do
exactly
what she was asking of them or pointing
out
how to improve they would rise to the
occasion after a short period
i'm talking about minutes and
aikido transforms she walks away to the
next one
it slowly deteriorates back to more or
less how they were
this repetition takes years and years
and finally the
all the students grow hopefully and um
find out about themselves perhaps
observing
their own weaknesses they may film
themselves from time to time
oh that's what i'm doing mom i couldn't
see that i didn't know that oh
i'm leaning too much oh i'm stepping too
quick oh why am i lifting my
foot up rather than my heel this is the
way to observe yourself
as well as others
aikido is a very demanding art and
because it's made up of so many
different
martial arts from different countries
why does it fascinate us so much
if we had to stick to one art it might
uh
be better we've got a goal that we can
achieve but it's so many different arts
chinese thinking japanese thinking
yeah from mongolia to
all the depths of the samurai
way of life but it's something that
intrigues us isn't that
and that's very important that you know
this in aikido
so observing observe the teachers
observe those teachers who were a very
high rank
sadly no longer here goes oceana
tomorrow senzi
i mean i can go on and on nisha sensei
what look at their face i was looking at
a video of um
tomorrow scentsy just a day or two ago
he's watching the ukis all the time
he knows how to do aikido he don't
blindfolded he doesn't need to work that
he's studying them he's watching them
what he's observing is the inside as
well as what the
outside action is doing he's permanently
connected
the feed with what we don't know what
we're
capable of doing is working all the time
the connection of his mind his
you see his eyes watching moving
and he'll be controlling the ukis
throwing them down as if they're just
light elasticated air
and they just fall down they don't know
how he's doing it
but he's connected to them he's observed
them
he's observed for so many years
but you must observe don't go inside
yourself
and think that you can control somebody
without being connected to them i hope
you found this of interest
and i'd like to keep talking in the
future
as well about going deeper and deeper
into ourselves and into the mind of
others
thank you for your time